bonjour bienvenue sur le studio dans le
studio de diagonale tv spéciale
nationale 2016 aujourd'hui je suis avec
un nouvel invité sur diagonale tc sylvia
colas beaubourg sylvia bonjour stéphane
alors si jacques aulas tu es déjà tu as
déjà été s'il y a championne de france
en 2007
oui exactement donc tu as déjà un titre
à ton actif donc forcément quand tu
joues le national et que tu l'a déjà
emporté c'est pas pour faire de la
figuration
non mais c'est très difficile de se
motiver
c'est difficile une fois qu'on a gagné
oui bien sûr qu'une fois qu'on a gagné
une fois c'est un peu plus difficile
alors après il ya le palmarès on peut
essayer d'accrocher un nombre de
victoires pour être pour essayer d'avoir
un record court oui bien sûr à chaque
fois on essaye de se mettre des nouveaux
défis pour pouvoir trouver quelque chose
plus intéressant oui voilà on essaie de
viser plus haut et donc d'augmenter le
nombre de victoires alors tu fais aussi
partie de l'équipe de france depuis des
années déjà un donc depuis un bon moment
donc tu es un des piliers de l'équipe de
france tu vas d'ailleurs joué les
prochaines olympiades exactement bakou
voilà avec mathieu cornette le
sélectionneur c'est l'ex capitaine
axonais ouais il est bien il est super
je vous s'occupe bien de vous aider
on est vraiment de chance de l'avoir
comme entraîneur et depuis des années il
a amené en fraîcheur qu'on n'avait pas
avant et va du coup ça se passe super
bien il est capable de nous motiver de
montrer de nouvelles façons de jouer et
de comment ça se passe à merveille
alors toi même tu es d une super joueuse
française tu fais partie bien sûr du top
français depuis depuis déjà plusieurs
années alors dans ce national tu fais un
bon début aurait pu faire même mieux je
pense parce que tu as raté sans doute à
une game face à hand à safran cela c'est
ça en finale un peu technique bon c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile parce que vous
étiez à au bout d'eux peut-être cinq
heures de jeu et il ya la fatigue qui
vient mais bon peu importe même même en
ratant seguin tu fais quand même bon
début surtout aujourd'hui tu as gagné
une victoire importante puisque ça te
permet de recoller en tout cas de suivre
sophie millet au classement et tu as tu
es juste derrière en fait 2e ex-aequo
maintenant avec amira almira skripchenko
qui bon c'est quand même une nouvelle
importante aujourd'hui a dû faire
forfait
je vais l'appeler soit oui alors on n'a
pas plus d'informations on ne sait pas
si on pensait qu'elle était
les taliban un médecin donc on n'en sait
pas plus on espère qu'elle pourra bien
sûr continuer nationale en attendant
elle a fait forfait donc sa relance un
peu aussi ce la course au titre et donc
sont finies et l'a emporté mais toi tu
es juste derrière grâce à cette victoire
qui était donc important sportivement tu
jouer face à julie fischer c'est une
nouvelle joueuse dans le national oui
qui s'était qualifié l'an dernier c'est
ça oui mais c'est aussi que je connais
un petit peu parce que nous avons déjà
joué quelques fois les matchs par équipe
fait moins bien sûr si une fille qui
progresse encore jeune qui est encore
jeune elle a un style assez particulier
donc c'est faut faire attention elle a
un style particulier oui c'est là un
style assez agressif d'accord et comme
les jeunes on sait jamais si un jeune
d'une année sur l'autre et il a pu
gagner 100 points au passage
c'est bien possible c'est ça le problème
alors on y va on va regarder cette
partie qui est une belle partie
stratégique alors tu as toi les noirs on
sait qu'on va peut-être regarder côté
noir tout simplement ça sera peut-être
mieux voilà ça tu as nancy mieux donc
ces partis alors elle choisit doit elle
jouer quatre tout attendait ça oui
d'accord sa préparation tranquille et la
sicile et dans ce bassin elle avait
plusieurs possibilités soit un jeu que
va laisser toi aussi parfois comme les
c3 pour j'avais prévu aux quelque chose
d'aussi elles attribuent à julien fermer
aussi donc tout attendu aussi à ça il
prépare et les deux donc d'habitude je
joue cavale et c6 way et c'est un fils
qui
jours fous des cinq en tout cas walesa
je voulais éviter la préparation d'un
projet aussi dit que je vais jouer aussi
c'est la bonne idée de jouer si les nos
vertes d'accord pour jouer début
d'accord d'accord j'avais envie d'entrer
dans le combat
ben ça c'est intéressant pour nous parce
qu'évidemment tu nous donne des clés de
préparation savoir comment jouer ça
l'air de rien on est au deuxième coup
mais mais effectivement tu sais ce
qu'elle joue d'habitude tu veu t as pas
envie qu'elle soit dans son élément et
acto et tu essaies de l'amener plus tôt
dans ton terrain quoi donc
il ya donc des c'est important ça voilà
c'est des choses auxquelles on fait pas
forcément attention quand on n'a pas à
ton niveau mais on voit là on essaie
d'être dans un terrain qu'il a nous nous
plaît et qui déplaît à l'adversaire
ouais c'est le combat psychologique
comme on appelle voilà comme si dans le
cas souvent c'est pourtant aussi de la
gagner donc on peut jouer
aussi en face ont déjoué des coucous
jours pour la première fois nous
surprendre l'adversaire donc là c'est
hélas sur trois ans à l'as est
surprenant c'est un coucou j'avais
oublié de le garder donc celle qui t'a
surpris en premier film we ah oui
d'accord et donc c'est vrai que c'est un
coup je n'aime pas trop jouer à wii donc
ouais mais donc elle a gagné un peu le
mini desbuquois et le mini début et
voilà c'est déjà par khalid et de blanc
il est très simple ils ont envie de
jouer d 4d 4 et ensuite de faire ces
quatre lignes au clair on va transposer
dans un mas loti à william thomas roxy
avec le four b2 derrière le clavier en
c3 mais pas trop il faut donc si moi
j'aime bien mais dans des zones et on
joue avec les blancs avec les noirs mais
pour cette partie je t'ai pas après
thérèse exactement 7 heures et de voilà
c'est ça cette partie tu te dis pas ça
voilà donc ces partis à 6 à 6 bon très
bien ce qu'est un coup classique d'un
six cylindres leur souvent foulé de
vue-là cela serait normal qu avait
laissé six c4 donc là c'est bien son
idée et en maraude si on gagne le set
avec la du dédoublement de cavaliers et
on va voir si importante d'ailleurs
parce que ça va déterminer la suite la
wii
oui parce que ici elle fait un petit
spot a été assez 3 alors que l'on peut
jouer des quatre maintenant elle est
obligée si tu veux t'en si elles veulent
transposer dans un amphi faut des gars
qu'on attendrait te faire [ __ ]
deux tirs oui mais gardez garder le
contrôle avec le fou ici exactement et
que valait 6 3 c'est mal joué
haskell ars le contrôle de la classe des
4 et oui donc en jouant calais des cas
finalement tu bloques ce maroc dia plus
il ya plus d'ouverture est là donc c'est
pas du tout la même
non pas du tout voilà donc là on entre
dans une position stratégique et si cet
arrangement elle ça les arrange pas du
tout parce que même si l échange avec
les poules de quatre imaginez hollande
de cat way
regardons cette variante qu'apple ait eu
deux curieux 2 simplement que ce soit
500 défends mon client du sur et la
différence dans les autres sur position
le pion c4 et 1 c2 donc peut faire
l'europe qui ont peu joué ces 3 alors
que la main est là et on peut pas jouer
ici être qu'à force par dessus tout
aussi sont des sylphes f4 je vais faire
des 6,9 et 6,8 ce jeu décisif je vais
faire cavaler sait si c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire f 5
là je vais avoir le contrôle sur les
cases noires avec fawcett et fauché cinq
oui et puis là tu vas toujours des
ruptures en base de baies 5 7 ans vit on
le classe g avec
j'ai égalisé les noirs ''sans tout
problème cette position donc là tu te
dis déjà j'ai au moins égaliser mais là
je suis contente de ma position d'accord
et elle je crois qu'elle était en train
de tomber c'est ce qu'est optique ou
c'est petit oubli et voilà ton jeu
parfois cité voilà on enlevait sur les
joues un peu vite
alors on va voir donc g3 et cavalli 6,6
alors voilà doublement de calais c'est
là que tu dises les cavaliers qui se
suivent
on a un double double les tours presque
un lecavalier pour remplacer l'autre en
cas dé change hélas ce truc cette case
elle est totalement man et noir voilà et
de petites erreurs des blancs c'est au
tour de contre eux donc fou g2 bon
pourquoi pas continuer son développement
quand tu va augmenter le contrôle des
six parce que tu va augmenter le
contrôle sur cette case et donc ça
empêche effectivement les blancs d'oeufs
voilà ça y est c'est fini c'est une
position serré c'est plus du tout la
même
petit rock foo j'essaie et le jus de
noix et les tours simple m c'est super
simple tu vas pouvoir en plus joué de
besseyre tu vas pouvoir le taux réduit
tu vas pouvoir peut-être plus tard jouer
des scènes quoique des 5 c politique à
ce que je fais dans la carte qui est
aussi mais je crois que bay 5 c'était
moi je voulais mais on va voir
tout à l'heure on va voir tout à l'heure
donc ici elle joue cavalier un bon balle
et c'est le seul jeu quelque peu à voir
maintenant si c'est parlant il parce
qu'il faut savoir que les cavaliers
quand ils sont un tandem comme ça oui
la prothèse va il ya le 2 et au cavalier
celui de c1 c6 qui fait rien oui donc
c'est ça qu on évite les échanges et
donc c'est bien joué
oui d'accord a oui oui parce que si elle
avait changé et bien finalement à offrir
une pièce active contre un cavalier qui
venait qui venait s'activer s'était
alors que les fictivement il est passif
la voie d'accord d'accord donc la petit
rock mais c'est bien et tout bien
retrouvé gisant donc parce que s'ils
essayent de faire que vos lèvres 2 c'est
pas possible parce qu'il est jeune donc
il ya des petites tactiques donc elle
est obligée de défendre ce faux d'accord
mais c'est possible parce que c'est
quand même pas super court là elle peut
aussi préparer à trois des quatre où
elle essaye de chercher un petit con te
laisser de chercher quelque chose
quelque chose aurait pu essayer de jouer
par f4 l'essayer au centre comme ça avec
4 f 5
et puis si les noirs vous 5 peut-être
joué 5 c'est de bloquer ce fou bons mais
ils peuvent jamais parce qu'il ya des
six oui en fait voilà donc qui s'ils
tombaient et la b5 tout de suite au
début j'ai pas facile du tout offert 25
je vais envie de jouer en position plus
solide j'avais envie de faire b6 des six
fours et 7 par ce signe pourtant que le
fossé vite il est placé sur la grande
diagonale à utah champ oui parce que
sinon par l'algérien oui parce que quand
les blancs faut vous faire f 4 les noirs
vont comparer avec les 5
on va pas laisser la relève l'entendre
l'espace urbain
mais le problème de au coût de 25
c'est la faiblesse de pioncer 5 à oui
biensur ce pion maintenant eh oui alors
que avec b 6 il avait pas de problème
mais là on peut là encore pour tout
j'avais des 6000 pourra se faire
attaquer par un sale état
nous donc ce pion peut s'avérer un peu
folle ça c'était par exemple un coup que
j'ai joué un peu vite et c'était
halloween précis alors là tout de suite
et on est tout de suite elle a vu et
donc elle joue qu'avec ce droit pour
mettre la pression sur une baisse est
vrai le belge eu sa chance à lui eu sa
chance alors avec un v6 d'accord
l'audition des six est possible aussi
des 6 mai dsk le 5 peut-être sur le d6
peut-être 5 c'est possible à tout de
suite
mêmes scènes tout de suite ah oui c'est
vrai il le cavalier là et est coincé oui
oui bien sûr donc il peut pas reprendre
et 6
donc si je reprends du pion ses seins
qui tombent si je reprends la foux si je
vous disais décisif aux 5 boeing prend
que valait plus que la vallée prendre
pour un fou tu donnes ton super fou de
faire cavaler aux 4 et donc oui oui oui
tu as toujours un problème sur ces cinq
actes saleh de parcours durant et oui
c'est cette mine de rien voilà en terre
et les faiblesses comme ça sans le voir
n est pas facile d'un v6 bon pour
l'accord plutôt que des six donc et
maintenant être quatre c'est bien f k
parce que elle veut aussi jouer aux cinq
peut-être aussi cavalier ou 4 et puis on
la taxe est simple et pourquoi pas dès 6
ans et même si intéressant peut-être que
joël fouet tous avec les bières fois
trois ans n'a pas peur de ben et 84
parce qu'il ya le côté remédier attaque
la dame elle bouge on revient avec le
fou et on a un problème sur ces 5
j'étais obligé de jouer des coups au
visage
oui mais
alors qu'à québec voilà donc tu veux
éliminer ce cet attaquant de la casse
ces cinq ici 20 tu joues qui a validé
quatre pour ça sachant que là tu es
toujours bien protégé par la dame par le
foulée des vnf est très dangereuse oui
prise prise est là et puis ce sont des
pillages c4 qui va être faible après
aussi enfin pour ça oui il ya beaucoup
de jeu donc elle revient et maintenant
voilà c'est l'heure voilà tranquille
donc l'atlas et là d'un coup ça va un
peu mieux
donc les noirs ont réussi à débloquer
toutes leurs pièces le fou mais
l'ambiance était bien placé alors que
ses deux chats sinon c'est ce que je
pense que non il n'a pas fait parce que
le coût normal se faire à toi à 3000
euros gagnés les c6 elle est peut-être
vous voyez venir revenir avec l'idée
faire le 5 et on peut faire ça aux
cavaliers en quatre mais voilà bien sûr
et puis aussi avec à trois peut-être on
pourrait même tenter bcb 4 il peut être
pour faire sauter le verrou on était
quand même tout 10 ans sert à quelque
chose
voilà en plus en plus la tour et
derrière il ya un vis-à-vis avec la dame
se passer des trucs
oui et donc elle fait pas ça m'a enlevé
des trois là c'est un peu un peu passif
c'est pas si ces puits alors du coup
c'est fini elle pourra plus jamais
remettre le cavalier là alors que l avez
compris que c'était une bonne idée donc
c'est ça qui est curieux long et puis
quand même jouer ça qu'elle est d'être
ici il y avait un autre coup qui était
possible de faire un g4 hausse bien sûr
oui j 4 pour lancer l'attaqué et le 5
les blancs ils sont obligés de chercher
en contrepartie font rien ben moi je
vais m'organiser les pièces petit à
petit et je vais commencer la taxe sur
elle dans les jours donc les
pleins ils sont obligés de jouer sur
l'ailé droit bien sûr et là tu peux
envisager fc non stratégiques cattoir
qui connut assez classique dans les
systèmes fermés d'ailleurs donc ici des
trois donc vous bessette détroit donc et
sans doute pas un très bon coin là c'est
court sur l'idée la position de pions
4ème et passifs voilà moins actif que
ces plans combien de voir et elle avait
compris l'importance que son carillon
détroit était bien ce que moi je vais
peut-être pour elle mais tant pis le fcn
quand même voilà donc là tu tues tu
ouvres un peu la colonne f
éventuellement quand tu veux la cire
tous deux au ps le jeu de dés blancs qui
est de faire f4 f5 tempe et chef 5
définitivement puis tu que tu fais une
petite pression sur quatre mine de rien
puisque ce fou et ils rêvent que de ça
que ça ça saute pour s'échanger et
affaiblir un peu le roi exact dam des
deux est là retour donc mon cavalier 4
et sert plus à rien et a fini son
travail puisque la joie des 3
voilà donc au final il revient pour
s'échanger éventuellement de nouveau en
d4 donc ici roche rachat de la part des
blancs mais je vois de wels en cas
d'échec et un seul coup prophylactique
quoi rester un peu le coup je sais pas
comment on continue aussi avec les
blancs et pour moi on peut faire tous
fait toujours le contraire je sais de
chercher h3g 4h deux tours gérons
essayer de vous livrer collonges et et
faire quelque chose on voit très bien
donc ici b4 maintenant donc là tu alors
approuvé c'est embêtant des cadres parce
que qu'est ce qui se passe car il ya
quatre ans oui tu peux venir à 5,65
mais c'est un peu un peux me passer un
peu parce qu'il fallait comme à lille
fait plus grand chose à 1,4 mais pour
moi c'était locaux seul coup qui était
possible dans cette position d'accord
parce qu'en même temps ces blocs mon
contre jeux wii et
et après ils toujours continuer avec
chacun put alors l'idée aussi c'est
peut-être si tu joues b4 calais car
quand tu vas jouer d'un bassin plus tard
tu arriveras à jouer sous ses 6es à
chasser ce cavalier puisque sinon c'est
adam elle est quand même passive ici il
va falloir donc viré ce cavalier juste
là pour défendre le monde qui ont cessé
de faire des saints oui puis aux rumeurs
que l'ami tu peux aussi être une tour
ensuite pour protéger nos pions et après
tu pourras du coup enlever la dame on
n'avait pas de problème d'accord donc d4
et l'a donc beaucoup elle va pas un 4
mai à eux deux pour essayer d'échanger
un des cavaliers a noté un corps hier 17
caisses des cats lecavalier qui peut
remplacer le fou tout est bien protégé
sauf que là ça mange des choses à dire
et une cavalière bien sûr parce que
évidemment c'est dans l'autre et passifs
comme tu le disais et après calais
prendre de dame prend hop ça y est
toutes les pièces sont actives
exactement
et parce que ça libère voyez tout de
suite l'action du fou donc voilà c'est
une simple réflexion de dynamisme et on
trouve la solution est toujours garé
tout seul très bien donc on continue up
dam des deux donc elle est la dame était
attaquée fait la bouche de toutes façons
et maintenant il faut trouver un plan à
cinq voix là tranquille normal parce que
maintenant qu'on a fixé la strueth
l'aveyron ont créé une rupture ici et
ouvrir sur la colonne a offert une
invasion côté dames 1 il peut rien faire
en fait parce que là c'est fini à la
plus de g4 f54 toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive elle doit faire chaque année
voilà pourquoi j'ai déjà faire quelques
essais d'ouvrir le jeu au maximum - et
bien sûr pour créer du contrôle parce
qu'ils n'ont elle va se faire étouffer
oui mais non elle le fait pas il fait
cavalier h3 donc bon allez c'est
d'activistes cavaliers il va venir ou là
mais là en fait ils arrêtent ils
attaquent rien puisque si c'est bien
protégé par l'opium faire que les aînés
que me lève toi pour l'échangé encore
toutes les pièces ouais mais c'est pas
ouais c'est alarmant le banc et c'est
dommage parce que lecavalier là est bien
placé pour g4 là c'est une erreur sans
doute aussi positionné de faire un ce
coup là pas forcément de s'adapter
puisque toi tu as un plan clair et
qu'elle n'a pas
joue pas un poète assez assez dynamique
pour contrer ce plan donc la menace de
gagner un pion c'est quand même embêtant
apprend béa prend bk vais les prendre
gagnon auquel pouvait défendre avec des
vidéos et c'est encore facile c'est
encore passif choisi de prendre mais il
ya même de lancer le pion à 2 qui est
faible donc tout reprend attaque à deux
à toi c'est normal envie d'enlever la
faiblesse ouais alors à 3 oui alors
effectivement donc si tu prends
évidemment fou prend et latour attaque
la dame valet donc donc tu ne prends pas
mais simplement up double
mes pièces en double tour et là il fait
une faute on oui on approche et vous
allez voir donc
le problème ici qu'on voit avec les
blancs c'est qu'ils se sont trompés
plusieurs fois détroit est un peu passif
puisqu'elles avaient compris qu'ils
avaient faiblesse enseigne à l'ap a mis
l'accent dessus ils auraient pu revenir
avec son cavalier dessus et 2 elle n'a
pas ouvert côté roy donc on n'a pas
ouvert côté roy les noirs finalement ont
les mains libres pour aller attaquer à
l'aide d'armes iso ils n'ont pas de
problèmes de défense donc ya pas de
problème alors que si on avait ouvert le
juste c'est plus délicat
être obligé de se défendre alors clair
comme il n'y a aucune menace
et voilà c'est le problème si on contre
attaque pavés on laisse l'adversaire
dérouler son jeu donc à prendre mais
hélas hélas peut-être pas calculer s'il
n'a pas vu un coup simple je sais pas
peut-être l'espérer d'emprunt je sais
pas mais là évidemment le problème c'est
qu'effectivement on voit tout de suite à
l'oeil c'est que ces deux pièces ici là
d'un v6 et dames et tour bk très bien ce
fou et cloud et c'est là que la tour
l'année n'est pas qu'est ce qu'on fait
sur option rouge et or on perd le fou et
si on bouge pas la tour il ya le tour
qui est menaces darier créer un double
un club supplémentaire
c'est délicat qu'est ce qu'elle aurait
pu faire ici mais c'est ce qu'elle a
fait à peu près il n'ya que ce à quoi on
aurait 2 j'ai pensé plutôt d'un c'est en
voilà des terrains pour sortir et ne pas
permettre un clouage ne pas permettre
les cloches de la dame mais tu vas quand
même
ah oui sur torse sur dame c'est en
question va faire tu va tripler ou non
tu vas tu fais ce que tu as joué quand
même tour à 2
sauf que si je
s'ils jouent tour à deux elle peut faire
part des quatre élèves le clonage
voilà fou prend des cas et échanger des
pièces alors voilà donc qu'est ce que tu
aurais fait ici est sans doute mais ça
gagne pas qu'avec eux deux a tout
simplement
cavalia 2 s'avère de gagner ça non
cavalia 2 attaque la dame et le fuet
emprise de la tour du fou de la dame
salaire de gagner simplement cac valeo 2
je peux faire les deux alors voyons si
oui et donc c'est fini et au plan les
rideaux prend b2 effet le taux latour
protège en même temps le cavalier
salaires foutu donc c'est déjà très dur
donc surtout prend b4 voilà les blancs
ont laissé voyez il suffit de laisser
l'initiative se dérouler sans
contre-attaqué pour se faire
complètement défoncée dr f2 bon essayer
d'obtenir mais voyez c'est trop passif
on peut pas tenir la tour à deux tout
simplement
et on peut dire c'est foutu coin parce
que là maintenant alors peut-être
essayer de boucher ici mais je sais pas
si on peut vraiment bouger parce que si
on joue aux 5
il y aura des six se sont surpassés elle
essaie de boucher mais bon il suffit de
d'abord en échange le fou très bien tout
reprendre et maintenant des six voies là
et on peut si vous prenez le problème
c'est que le cavalier sort et puis c'est
fini puisqu'on peut pas bouger le la
tour c'est le bouge l'oeuf ou éternue si
le football c'est la tour est perdu
donc à tous qui sommes donc des six pour
faire sauter ce verrou afin que le fou
viennent de donner le coup le coût final
quoi je commande bien qu'elle abandonne
ici
voilà qui voyait simple simple bravo
superbe tranquille en fait bon voilà
erreur stratégique
on peut dire parce que c'est oui c'est
une partie qui s'est décidé sur des
subtilités de début et puis finalement
oui les erreurs
elle a oublié qu'il fallait qu'elle
qu'elle est une initiative pour contrer
ton plan ce que toi tu avais un plan
elle n'avait pas alors et pas de quoi
contre-attaqués ça lui fera une bonne
leçon pour la suite
alors on va dire ça comme ça en tout cas
toi c'est bon pour le pour le tournoi
parce que ça fait 2 victoires 2 nuls et
aurait même pu faire un peu mieux je
répète mais en tout cas tu es bien placé
alors t'as pas encore joué les
meilleures joueuses ont donc c'est
l'acceptation à venir voilà et donc là
tu es préparer oui un petit peu et je ne
prépare encore l'avocat voilà alors tu
étais tu as aussi tu as un entraîneur
avec toi qui peut-être de cp malick avec
moi didier voilà c'est ça qui fait
l'accession oui c'est ça êtes-vous
préparé ensemble tu l'aide
il était de jouer ensemble ah ouais ça
vous donner des conseils quand même
d'accord discuté c'est donc dans la
famille collègues
d'accord elle est super voilà donc une
belle victoire de sylvia colas à un
moment important du tournoi après quatre
ans donc elle est 2e un demi point donc
voilà déjà gagné le titre a déjà fait
des podiums
elle est dans l'équipe de france est
donc et donc elle est en course pourquoi
pas pour un deuxième titre et ce titre
2016 à agen merci beaucoup sylvia merci
merci de nous avoir suivi sur le studio
diagonale tv et je vous dis donc à une
prochaine
au revoir